is asking for your help in identifying  multiple people involved with the string  of burglaries across town the suspects  have been linked to 17 incidents over  the past month police say they break  through the front glass doors of the  businesses in the early morning hours  usually between 2 30 to 5 30 in the  morning targeting cash drawers and safes  the suspects typically dressed in black  hoodies and blue or black jeans police  have connected them to three different  cars during these crimes a grade  two-door sedan a white jeep patriot and  a black four-door sedan anyone with  information is urged to call crime  stoppers at the number on your screen